we are kicking off the ultimate sports
weekend here in las vegas at the nhl fan
fair ahead of tomorrow's big all-star
game yeah they have a tremendous amount
going on there jillian lopez now joining
us live from the convention center
she is in full hockey gear jillian as a
goalie
hey you guys so this is just one of the
many things you can experience here at
the nhl fanfare at the convention center
this is for all ages clearly i am decked
out this is just one of the attractions
you can check out i'm getting ready to
block some some pucks and hopefully you
know not let the other team score some
goals on me i even have my heels on this
is so much fun i'm going to take you
guys back bear with me we'll see how i
do but i'm in full gear this is just one
of the fun things you can check out here
at the fan fest i'm making my way in
front of the goal
i've been learning how to stand properly
so we'll see if the golden knights want
to put me in after that all right we're
ready let's try this
okay a lot faster hey i did it a lot
faster than i thought it was going to be
oh wow i need some other pads right here
all right
we're putting my skills to the test i've
locked a few goals
all right i'll send it back to you guys
as i'm practicing my my hockey skills
over here come check out the fanfare
it's going on until nine o'clock tonight
and through sunday send it back to you
hey good job jill there's a number of
blocks there
first man effortless